les conséquences par rapport
à rambouillet les élèves parlent aux
élèves de boue des lycéens à 6 des
collégiens la team anti harcèlement du
lycée bascans intervient ce mercredi au
collège voisin le public ciblé les 6e
il faut pas le garder pour soi même
parce que ça pourrait aggraver encore
corriger la situation
c'est aussi une richesse pour nous que
d'avoir des lycéens pour certains qui
sont d'anciens élèves du collège puisque
la parole et se montrent plus facile
entre pères et du contre élèves même
s'il ya une petite différence d'âge des
temps théorique mais aussi plus ludique
les membres de la team créé des jeux
pour partager les notions liées aux
harcèlements et créer une relation de
confiance des personnes qui vont se
mettre de côté des personnes qui vont
vite quitté les classes de cours on les
voit assez souvent et puis l'a
apparemment jetée un train discuté avec
quelques élèves qui m'ont fait qu'ils
m'ont prévenu qu'ils avaient été suivies
dur c'est vrai qu'ils sont en train de
subir
moi même j'ai été victime de harcèlement
et si on peut éviter à des élèves
2000 sa situation va c'est c'est
vraiment important pour moi en tout cas
et au moins avec ses interventions
souvent les élèves se confier à nous à
l'origine deux élèves du lycée bascans
lancé en 2018 elle regroupe maintenant
70 jeunes ils sont encadrés par des
responsables de l'établissement c'est
eux qui font l'information auprès des
élèves nous adultes on est là pour les
accompagner les guider c'est pas nous
les adultes qui impose aux noms
formation vraiment c'est eux qui
construisent on les accompagne on régule
on les aide on les guide certain nombre
aujourd'hui dans un cursus d'études
supérieures continue à sensibiliser
blandine est présente depuis 2018
ludmila depuis 2019
notre ligne directrice et elle est 6e ou
aujourd'hui on s'est beaucoup diversifié
notamment au lycée basse quand on fait
des interventions à la demande des
professeurs si on voit on détecte un cas
on prévient noba du coup les principales
et savent eux d'agir et on n'agit pas
assez pas à nous deux on n'est pas un
régulièrement des problèmes c'est on
avertit 8 heures ce jeudi matin une
partie de la team est sur le pont pour
cette journée nationale de lutte contre
le harcèlement de nombreux rendez vous
sont proposés on a aménagé en jeu du
loup garou pour en faire une chasse à la
paire qui permettra de montrer le
principe de harcèlement donc c'est
également de la prévention montrer le
principe de harcèlement au sein d'un
lycée dans une école avec vraiment le
harceleur le harceler les parents en
2019 le 30 20 plateformes des deux
victimes et aux parents a été sollicité
près de 80 mille fois